the Muller investigation heats up again
Omarosa promises shocking tapes and
Democrats prepare for election 2018 i'm
ben shapiro this is the venture Piro
show oh so many things to get you today
all of them irritating and foolish don't
worry we'll get through it together but
first I want to remind you that you are
not the average investor sation invest
like the average investor you should be
attempting to outsmart average you
should be attempting to do better than
the average investor and that is why you
need betterment betterment is the better
way the smarter way to manage your money
it's an investment tool for those who
refuse to settle for average investing
it's cutting-edge technology combined
with human expertise it's technology
that is designed to give you more from
your investments unlimited expert advice
designed to help you make smart
financial decisions tax efficient
investing strategies that give you an
edge low transparent fees constant
access to information and tools that
allow you to track progress toward your
goals so you can always feel like a
smart savvy investor it's basically an
online financial adviser you know I'm
somebody who uses a financial advisor
because I don't have time to keep track
of my own money I'm not the person who's
gonna being sifting through all the
stock reports what you need is somebody
to help you do that
and that is where betterment comes in
betterment gives you technology that
allows you the transparency to see where
your money is it allows you all this
information it allows you up to date
information that's available to you all
the time and low transparent fees it's
not like you're getting charged on a per
trade basis for example betterment you
have to outsmart average and the best
way to do that is by signing up today
and getting up to one year managed for
free go check it out right now at
betterment comm slash Shapiro that's
better mint.com slash Shapiro again be
et te RM ent betterment comm slash
capiro use that slash appear to let them
know he sent you plus you can get up to
one year manage for free so go check it
out right now get investing get smart
with your cash outsmart average
betterment comm slash of Shapiro okay so
I'm a Rosa so uhm Rosa has long been
known as one of the most solid citizens
in our country right she's long been
known as a person that you would trust
with your life if you were suicidal
she's long been known as somebody who
you would certainly believe where she to
make any and every claim at least that's
how the media are treating her these
days in the media that hated Omarosa up
until let's see 37 seconds ago now they
think that she has
tons of credibility to speak about who
president trumpets the lady who on tape
two years ago was saying everyone would
be forced to bow before President Trump
that is not a paraphrase that is a
direct quote he said the people would be
forced to kneel before Zod
right that lady now is saying that she
is sorry she was ever part of these odd
regime and she feels quite terrible that
she flew with Zod out of the for bit of
the out of the mirror Forbidden Zone and
now she is she is very sorry and wishes
abjectly Lee to beg apology of you and
to remind you the President Trump is in
fact a vicious and brutal racist so she
says that she has all sorts of Trump
tapes and she now says that there is a a
production staff member on the
apprentice who wants to drop tapes of
President Trump using the n-word now if
this sounds like deja vu that's because
it is we had this exact discussion back
in 2016 there were rumors that there
were tapes from the set of The
Apprentice where Donald Trump was using
the n-word and none of those ever came
forth there's a lot of talk about
whether Mark Burnett who's the producer
of The Apprentice was hiding those tapes
or whether he was just friends with
Trump and didn't want those tapes to get
out well now Omarosa is resurfacing
those rumors and she says that there is
indeed a staff member who wants to wait
till October to drop those tapes if
those tapes were to drop it obviously
would be a major problem for the
president not because I think his base
of support would dissipate I think
people who are loyal to Trump are loyal
to Trump through thick and thin but
because all of the stuff that people
have said is racially charged would
suddenly look very different if the
president habitually uses the advert
right the president habitually uses
racist slurs then all the stuff that
feels racially charged or racially
tinged suddenly shifts over into the
category of probably racist but is that
tape out there well there's no evidence
that tape actually is out there
nonetheless Omarosa is pushing this and
Chris Matthews around hi Bob very eager
to hear about it yup in the morning tell
me they show Ron in here
talk about racism Omarosa I hate but now
I love her because she's saying bad
stuff about Trump Chris Matthews I'm a
rough cow I believe that they're using
it for politically motivated
things in fact they may be for November
before November and they saw it on it
took it on themselves to actually
document this so that they could
actually expose him for the races that
he is okay so now I'ma Rossa says that
he's a racist
she shoes out there the entire campaign
talk about what an honor
Trump was she gets fired because she's a
terrible employee and then she leaves
the White House and suddenly Trump is a
racist if this feels a little bit as
though she is turning and wheeling on
Trump because she's mad at him that's
because that's exactly what this is so
president Trump is in his own inimitable
fashion takes to Twitter to respond
because this is the reality show we all
bargain for okay let's be real about
this this is what you wanted to see was
it not when you turned into The
Apprentice this is what you wanted to
see you are getting the show that you
took that remote control and decided to
TiVo and now you're getting to enjoy it
break out the popcorn break out the
jelly beans because this is how it's
going to go from here until the end of
the administration President Trump
tweets out this Mark Burnett he calls to
say there are no tapes of The Apprentice
where I used such a terrible and
disgusting word as attributed by wacky
and deranged amarosa so I like that
every day now actually hurt her nickname
expands so she started off as wacky
Omarosa
she's now wacky and deranged Rama Rosa
tomorrow Oh be wacky deranged and insane
Omarosa so she's sort of like in
Austrian Prince just adds names as time
continues just it's her Trump continues
I don't have that word in my vocabulary
and never had she made it up look at her
many recent quotes saying such wonderful
and powerful things about me a true
champion of civil rights until she got
fired
Omarosa had zero credibility with the
media they didn't want interviews when
she worked in the White House now that
she says bad about me they will talk to
her fake news here's the thing Trump's
actually right about this obviously the
media hated Amuro so they thought that
it was a joke shoes in the White House
because it was a joke that she was in
the White House because she never should
have been hired because the president
didn't hire all the best people he hired
Omarosa of all the people in the United
States he went hire Omarosa but when he
says that the media are treating Omarosa
with a strange new respect that of
course is a hundred percent true then he
says when you give a crazed crying
lowlife a break and give her a job at
the White House I guess it just didn't
work out good work by general Kelly for
firing quickly firing that Doug okay so
some people today are saying oh it's
racist racist the Trump would call her a
dog right he calls her a crazed crying
lowlife and says he gave her a break I
liked it for President Trump every time
he hires somebody it's that he gave them
their big break in life it's a out of
the charity of his heart he hired
because he's such a charitable fellow
president trumpets that's what he does
he's just such a nice guy okay but the
idea that he's a racist because he
called Omarosa
a dog is just silly here is a mere
smattering of the people he has called
the dog in the past on Twitter alone
okay and it's always in the same context
he loves the phrase fired like a dog
which begs the question how many dogs
has he actually fired cuz that's weird
like do you fire a dog our dog's known
for being fired
it's a strange from the phrase but the
president has said this many many times
so here's what he said about David
Gregory formerly of NBC David Gregory
got thrown off of TV by NBC fired like a
Doug now he's on CNN being nasty to me
not nice exclamation point
Mitt Romney had his chance to be a
failed president but he choked like a
dog I don't know what he has against
dogs like I'm not a dog person but he
needs to go over to like puppy spot or
something and really get to know some
dogs because he's kind of mean he says
Moo McMiller
I'm now going to teach you a big boy a
lesson about lawsuit in finance
you ungrateful Doug Minnie says about
sloppy Steve ban and this is my favorite
cuz I don't like so you ban he's a jerk
he's now sloppy steve has been dumped
like a dog by almost everyone and then
there's bill maher fired like doug and
then there's Arianna Huffington she is a
Doug who wrongfully comments on me and
then there's Reverend Wright and Barack
Obama he says the Reverend Wright was
dumped like a dog and then there's eric
erickson who was fired like a dog and
then there's reverend wright who was
also again dumped like a dog and then
there was glenn back who was burned like
a dog and then there was David Axelrod
who was a dog and then there's George
Will who was thrown off ABC like a dog
and then there was Chuck Todd who was
not quite fired like a dog but Trump
thought he was going to be fired like a
dog and there was brent bozell who came
to his office begging for money like a
dog and then there's eric erickson
again fired like a dog and then mubarak
who was dropped like a dog there was Ted
Cruz who scapegoated his capable
director of communications fired like
Doug and finally the best one involves
of course this this is a classic of the
genre fired like a dog I mean it's a
whole genre right if Blockbuster Video
still existed there would actually be a
full section of dog references by
President Trump be like fired like a dog
one fired like a dog to the revenge okay
so he's waited this is this is the
it's the best one this is from October
17th 2012 Robert Pattinson should not
take back Kristen Stewart she cheated on
him like a dog and would do it again
just watch he can do much better so
Before we jump to he's a racist we might
want to say he's a speciesist he doesn't
like dogs he's very very mean to dogs
you thought Mitt Romney was mean to dogs
when he put a dog on top of his car and
drove around all that stuff President
Trump every time he has something bad to
say about a person he likens that person
into a dog so there's that but I love
that the BDI are treating he called home
roses oh he's a racist because she's a
black woman that's why he calls her a
dog
no I called her dogs doesn't like her
and for some reason he's got this phrase
stuck in this said one of the one of the
funny things about you know delving into
Trump's Twitter is whenever you think
that he's tweeted something that is
brand new as soon as you delve into his
past you realize that he has said it
1,000 times before we've had this sort
of thing with President Trump before so
I remember when he did this thing where
he mocked Sergey Kowalewski who was a
columnist for The New York Times and
remember he did these hand motions that
made it look like he was mocking a
disabled reporter and this became a
statement repeatedly that he was mocking
the disabled reporter not just mocking
the disabled reporter but mocking him
for the disability any ideas that he was
doing it because he knew Kowalewski was
disabled and so he started doing his
hands in in sort of a curled up fashion
in order to mock Kowalewski x' to scoop
disability and then it turns out that if
you go back through his tapes of him
mocking people he's constantly doing
these weird hand motions every time he
refers to somebody he doesn't like so is
he mocking the reporter yes was he doing
it for the disability no the truth is
that one of the reasons people give
Trump a lot of leeway on him being a
jerk is good is a jerk to everybody but
I'm surprised that we're still fighting
this fight like he's constantly a jerk
to most the president has two categories
in life when it comes to the people he
deals with either they're wonderful
people who say great things about me and
therefore deserve jobs at the White
House no matter how bad they are at
their job or they should be fired like a
Doug because they're the worst people in
the world right and everything breaks
down into these two categories is that
the president has any forty magda plan
like when he's nice to Putin he's not
nice to Putin because Putin and Trump
were on the phone late at night making
sweet love to one another it wasn't that
it's that Putin has said in the past
you've got a strong month but I have
been pump and then Trump's like I like
that guy
it's great and then the minute the Putin
does something Trump doesn't like you
should be fired like a Doug that's
that's really it's it's those are the
only two polls for president Trump
yeah and that's that is what it is like
is it my favorite thing no but are we
getting exactly what we bargained for of
course we're getting exactly what we
bargained for okay but the media are
responding to all of this with the
predictable outrage that you knew that
they would we'll get to that in just one
second first let's talk about the fact
that you have a credit card bills let's
talk about the fact you have some
outstanding costs that you want to pay
or you want to do some construction on
your house bottom line is you need some
sort of swing loan and with Lending Club
you can do all the stuff you can top
consolidate your debt or pay off credit
cards with one fixed monthly payment
since 2007 Lending Club has helped
millions of people regain control of
their finances with affordable
fixed-rate personal loans you know trips
to a bank know high interest credit
cards all you do is go to Lending Club
com tell them about yourself how much
you want to borrow pick the terms that
are right for you if you're approved
your loan is automatically deposited
into your bank account in as little as a
few days so go check it out right now
Lending Club is the number one
peer-to-peer lending platform over
thirty five billion dollars in loans
issued all you have to do is go to
Lending Club comm slash Ben that's
Lending Club comm slash binding check
irate in minutes you can borrow up to
forty grand
that is Lending Club comm slash Ben
again Lending Club comm slash ban all
loans made by web bank member FDIC Equal
Housing lender there's no reason for you
to have these high interest credit cards
just keep racking up debt that instead
you should go over to lending club check
out your options and again it's a very
easy process I've checked it out myself
Lending Club comm slash Ben go check it
out right now borrow up to forty grand
check it rates in minutes Lending Club
comm slash Ben go check that out
all right so nonetheless Omarosa
continues to say that she has the goods
on president Trump unfortunately she
actually had a little Penn bomb so she
apparently had a little pen that had in
it a recording device okay this is the
latest accusation how was she recording
this stuff she wasn't using her phone is
the accusation by a Shara Lee over at
over on Twitter calm he's a reporter and
he suggests that she was carrying around
a pen that recorded things the great
irony of this of course is that as you
recall back during the 2016 election
Corey Lewandowski grabbed a reporter
named Michelle fields because she might
have had a little pen bomb it turns out
that the pen bomb it was actually a pen
recording device and it was carried
James bond-like by Omarosa into the West
Wing because
everything is stupid because all that
you see this pen you never know you
never know gang what's in this pit in
any case she claims that she has Trump
on tape doing all sorts of terrible
things here is the most damning material
this is she gave the tape to CBS
apparently she was talking with Katrina
Pierson who was a once and future member
of the Trump team and Katrina page was
talking about the supposed n-word tape
that was floating around the offices of
The Apprentice or somesuch
and here is Omarosa talking with Katrina
Pierson because our long national
nightmare of people who shouldn't be on
TV never ends here we go okay so hatred
s Katrina Pierson the very end saying he
said it he said the n-word and he is
embarrassed okay well we don't actually
have evidence that any of this was said
when the evidence comes out then we'll
have to talk about the implications for
the administration left to talk about
the implications for future electoral
prospects the the kind of national
implications of having a president who
has used the n-word in the last 10 years
if that ends up being a thing that
actually happened but if the best that
amorosa can do is come up with a comment
from Katrina Pierson that's going to be
pretty weak sauce that's that's pretty
weak sauce remember Katrina Pierson is a
person who worked for Ted Cruz then
worked for President Trump and then
suggested it was okay when President
Trump implied that via national via the
National Enquirer that Katrina Pearson
had an affair with Ted Cruz none of
these people are real high on the
credibility list none of these people
really like you wouldn't trust them to
handle your finances like III really
honest to god I would not trust these
people to handle my safety deposit box
and I'm supposed to believe that they
have all of the all of the goods on on
president Trump or that I'm supposed to
trust President Trump here's my view
when I can't trust anybody have to wait
for evidence to come out otherwise this
is just a bunch of media nonsense
there's a reason by the way that
amaurosis book still hasn't reached
number one on Amazon it's because nobody
believes anything she has to say even
members of the media are looking at her
and saying yeah this
this is not the Spree weak stuff like
there's pretty weak stuff okay so now I
want to talk in brief about the the
Muller investigation so this is
hysterically funny Peter struck you'll
recall is the charming and wonderfully
smug fellow who appeared before Congress
recently to talk about why he was such a
good guy he's such a good guy that Peter
struck sent text messages to his lover
both of them were married to other
people at the time about why he didn't
want President Trump to be President he
said he would stop President Trump for
being president in at that time he was
leading both the Hillary Clinton email
investigation and the Russia
investigation which begs the question or
at least it prompts the question as to
was there only one employee at the FBI
like could they actually have hired
somebody else to do something over there
apparently Peter struck was the entire
show in any case Peter struck was
texting about why Trump shouldn't be
president at the same time he was
investigating both presidential
candidates that it turns out is bad
policy well struck was fired yesterday
from the FBI he was fired because of
those texts and because the Inspector
General of the DOJ in his report found
that he could not actually credibly
clear struck of accusations of bias he
didn't know exactly how strux bias had
affected the investigation and he'd have
to investigate that further but struck
had to go
so what instructed the struck gets fired
and then his lawyer releases a statement
saying that this is a political hit here
is Struck's lawyer from Vancouver Island
apparently doing this via Skype because
only the best and here he is on NBC News
talking about why this is a political
hit I don't think that you can
rationally reach any conclusion other
than it was political it's difficult to
believe given the steady drumbeat of
text demonizing Pete from the president
and all the calls on Capitol Hill by
Republicans for Pete to be fired that
that didn't play a role okay the reason
he was fired is because the IG report
said that Struck's texts quote
potentially indicated or created the
appearance that investigative decisions
were impacted by bias or improper
considerations the IG report also said
that Struck's behavior was quote not
only indicative of a bias State of Mind
but even more seriously implies a
willingness to take official action to
impact the presidential candidates
electoral prospects the report also
found that
strux decision to prioritize the Russia
investigation over the Hillary
investigation could have been biased it
said quote under these circumstances we
did not have confidence that Struck's
decision to prioritize the Russian
investigation over following up on the
mid-year related investigative lead
that's the Hillary related investigative
lead the Weiner computer was free from
bias the report concluded strux
activities were quote antithetical to
the core values of the FBI and the DOJ
hard to claim that that is a political
firing when the Inspector General of the
DOJ is openly saying that this guy
basically destroyed any credibility he
ever had okay so what instruct you after
he was fired the first thing he did
because this is the stupid world we live
in now Peter struck immediately once you
go fund me no I am not kidding and then
he started a go fund me to fund for his
legal bills even though he does not
actually have legal bills within 24
hours he had raised over a quarter
million dollars for his legal-defense
fund because everything is stupid so I
just want to point out how dumb
Democrats and leftists who are doing
this are in the last two years they've
made heroes out of James Comey a man who
undermined the credibility of the FBI
and may very well have gotten Donald
Trump elected remember it was James
Comey is reopening of the investigation
into Hillary Clinton a week before the
election that may have sunk her in the
swing states just enough that she loses
the election they've made him into a
hero right he is the leader of the
resistance now now they're making
Omarosa into the leader of the
resistance they've made Michael avenatti
a legitimate presidential candidate the
lawyer for a porn star they've made him
a legitimate presidential candidate
based on the fact that his clients want
heads once had sex with Trump during
Shark Week like that that is it
legitimately they're making Michael
avenatti he's now running for president
he's in Iowa right now organizing
seriously they're not polling on him by
the way he'll win a primary okay Michael
having out he runs he will win a primary
because this is what Democrats are now
he's a more interesting and exciting
kans in it than Kamala Harris okay and
and now they're also making a hero out
of Peter struck who's complete battery
of the Trump and Hillary investigations
also probably led to Trump being elected
remember the only reason that Hillary
Clinton's investigation was reopened
that close to the election even though
the FBI knew about weiners laptop in
late September is because Peter struck
decided
Aurra ties the russia investigation over
the hillary investigation and then by
the time they got around to looking at
the hillary stuff it was week before the
election a to reopen it so the democrats
are now raising money for james comey
and peter struck two of the people that
hillary clinton i think has the most
right to blame for her gigantic
electoral failure so well done democrats
you guys are just you're on top of it
you're just on top of it raising money
for Peter struck I'm sure he will use it
to pad his latest love nest with the
person he is not married to he's just a
delight my goodness okay but don't worry
things get even stupider they get even
stupider just wait we're gonna talk
about all the stupidity first we need to
talk about your skill set so you don't
want to be one of these stupid people
you know one won't be one of these
people whose chief qualification for
being on TV is that you once brought a
pen into the West Wing you want to be
somebody who actually has a skill set to
share and one of the ways that you can
make your skillset better is by going
over to skill share skills shares an
online learning platform with over
20,000 classes in business design
technology and more you can take classes
in social media marketing illustration
data science mobile photography creative
writing you name it you've got an expert
teaching a class on it
and whether you're trying to deepen that
professional skill set or start a side
hustle or just explore a new passion
skill share is there to keep you
learning and thriving so go check them
out right now we use skill share here at
the offices I've taken classes in social
media monitoring and and some data
analysis I've taken classes in
watercolors because hey a dude's got to
relax you can go check it out over at
skill share right now and you get two
months of skills share for just 99 cents
when you use skill share calm slash trip
hero again skill share calm slash
prepare to start your two months right
now for just 99 cents once you start
learning you're not gonna want to stop
go check it out skill share calm slash
Shapiro right now for just 99 cents you
get two months of skill share skill
share calm slash up here to let them
know that we sent you okay so as I say
things get even stupider than Peter
struck starting a GoFundMe how how could
they possibly get stupider you ask aha
I'm so glad you asked here's how they
get stupider Roger stone is now being
investigated by the Muller investigation
so the Muller investigation is looking
at Roger stone why because Roger stone
was a go-between for WikiLeaks right he
was hanging out with the WikiLeaks folks
they're a bunch of direct messages
between him and WikiLeaks WikiLeaks of
course turns out to be a Russian front
group coordinating closely with the
Russian government in the release of
Hillary Clinton's emails
so now the Muller investigation is
looking at whether maybe Roger stone was
working with WikiLeaks to funnel extra
information from Hillary Clinton's
hacked emails to the Trump campaign
that's basically what they are looking
at well The Daily Caller
is reporting that Roger stone is is now
the target of the witch-hunt and Roger
stone who is legitimately just a dummy I
mean really how do I know that Roger
stone is a dummy you know the guy with
the giant tattoo of Nixon on his back
well there's that we can start with the
giant tattoo of Nixon on his back but
then there is also the fact that he
tweeted out today today a graphic I'm
not kidding about this again I have to
ask him clarifying that I'm not kidding
because if you had told me this is what
politics was gonna be like when I got
into it I definitely would have gone I
would have gone and continued playing in
a string quartet like really he tweeted
this out and you actually put this out
on Instagram okay it is a picture of
Sean Hannity Mike Pence Sarah Huckabee
Sanders Roger stone Devon Nunez Donald
Trump and Rudy Giuliani wearing uniforms
that look like astronauts and then it
says blow it space force in space no one
can hear you why they are all wearing
patches in these uniforms of swastikas
swastikas with a little rocket and Roger
stone put the census I love this proud
to be in this crew but the only wise
being told are by liberal scumbags now
why you ask would Roger stone tweet out
a picture of himself wearing a swastika
along with other members of the Trump
administration and Sean Hannity because
he's stupid that's the answer the answer
is because he's a dum-dum Sir Roger
stone has an op ed over at the Daily
Caller about why he is the target of the
witch hunt one of stones rules he says
is the only thing worse than being
talked about is not being talked about
even I may have taken exception to that
rule last Friday again only the best
people only the best people were
associated with the term campaign and
the reason this is irritating folks is
because all of this is easily avoidable
and continues to be easily avoidable but
we're not going to avoid it we're gonna
steer directly into this crap storm he
says if you followed the news last
Friday you know that my longtime friend
Kristin Davis testified before special
counsel Robert Mullins grand jury and my
longtime associate and wingman Andrew
Miller was held in contempt for his
refusal to testify for the grand jury
that a subpoena was dropped on Randi
cretak oh who despite his public denials
was the source who first told me that
WikiLeaks had the goods on Hillary and
would release them in October
it was a deep state trifecta Andrew
Miller's contempt citation is a bit more
complicated
his appeal may be problematic for Muller
down the road Muller is running a
criminal II abusive constitutionally
unaccountable professionally and
politically incestuous conspiracy of
ethically conflicted cronies colluding
to violate my fourth fifth sixth
amendment rights and those of almost
everyone who had any sort of political
or personal association with me in the
last ten years he has conducted a
supposedly comprehensive investigation
of a very narrow and limited issue as an
open-ended totally limit limitless grand
prosecution with absolutely no
articulable or even identifiable
criminal predicates to substantiate it
as a lawful investigation even under
ordinary circumstances well I mean they
did brag that you were like best friends
with WikiLeaks I mean there was that and
then you also bragged about how you were
tight with Trump so there's that as well
and again maybe Muller finds nothing but
the the grand prosecution how dare they
target me Roger stone I am clean as know
okay so here he continues he says
Muller's team of partisan prosecutors
seeks to prove the unprovable that I
received allegedly hacked emails from
the Russians or WikiLeaks and passed
them on to Donald Trump this threadbare
false narrative is harped on endlessly
by slugs at MSNBC and other despicable
fake news outlets now because of the
accuracy of my tweets in which I merely
followed the tweets of WikiLeaks and the
many public interviews of WikiLeaks
publisher you Julian Assange Muller and
his hitmen seek to frame some motocross
charge of defrauding the United States
this of course is based on a false and
unproven assumption that Assange is a
Russian agent and WikiLeaks is a Russian
front neither of which has been proven
in a court of law okay so if his defense
that WikiLeaks is not a Russian front
good luck with that one good luck with
that one because it turns out the high
level of coordination between WikiLeaks
in the Russian government is obvious to
anyone who spent any time looking at
this issue again he maintains that that
WikiLeaks is some sort of independent
agency now maybe all this comes to
nothing but the fact that Roger stone is
now being dragged into all of this
demonstrates that the campaign had
serious problems from the very start now
should any of this really impact the
presidency should any of this really be
of any sort of consequence to the Trump
presidency I don't think so I really
don't think that any of this ends up
being a big deal in the end that said I
do think that things have become so
stupid on every side that it's diff
to tell what is real from what is not I
want to say stupid on every side I mean
the the left perception of this case is
just as stupid so the Washington Post
editorial board for example they say the
only way for us to really believe that
anyone is innocent in this case is for
Trump to talk directly with Robert
Muller and they write this whole
editorial saying there's no need to fear
Muller mr. president if you've nothing
to hide of course that's not true okay
as a lawyer that's not true the first
rule of wiring is tell your client to
shut his face really that is the first
rule of any sort of criminal lawyer ring
shut your head don't talk okay if it
doesn't matter if you're innocent
doesn't matter if you're guilty do not
talk to the cops it's actually the first
rule of wiring if they see you as a
potential defendant because all you can
do is give them evidence that is going
to either lead them down the path toward
prosecuting you or is going to lead them
to look into you more closely
all right the fact is that if you want
to convey something to the police you
can always do so through a lawyer but if
the police are bringing you in for an
investigation the chances that they're
going to be asking you a bunch of
questions to exonerate you is probably
close to nil right it's pretty low and
that's particularly true when you are
talking about a political politically
oriented prosecution like Muller this
idea that Trump should get in a room
with Robert Muller and that he has no
risk at all if he just tells the truth
first of all Trump is a pathological
problem with telling the straight truth
right the guy exaggerates on a regular
basis and having being a lawyer means
taking things both literally and
seriously the case that's been made for
Trump is that you are supposed to take
things seriously but not literally okay
that's a fair case Selina Zito has made
it Abele the idea that when Trump says
stuff we all just kind of go yeah he's
exaggerating but we know what he means
right but we know what he means in
lawyer land but we know what he means is
not natural defense in lawyer land what
you say is literally what you say and we
take it at face value and that means
that they'd be fools to actually put
Trump in a room with Robert Muller but
the Washington Post really wants it they
say this silly game has gone on far too
long the country was attacked mr. Muller
is trying to determine what happened the
president should be eager to help the
country learn and move on instead his
lawyers have spent the summer hemming
and hawing about the right circumstances
for an interview I don't remember the
same sort of the same sort of mitigating
feelings from the Washington Post with
regard to president Trump testifying
let's say this summer has brought
increasingly dire reminders that Russia
interfered with 20
election and that it intends to continue
meddling in the country's democracy if
mr. Trump has done nothing wrong and
intends to tell the truth he should
welcome mr. Mullins questioning and do
everything possible to hasten the
special counsels final report ok this is
the same argument that if you have
nothing to hide from the police and they
should be able to put a camera in your
house if you have nothing to worry about
criminally there's no reason you
shouldn't allow the police to simply
search your premises at any time the
whole point of restricting Authority is
that authority can be abused and we
don't necessarily have to we don't
necessarily have to assume guilt in
order to assume that that authority can
be used to go after folks and that
that's generally been true ok in just a
second I want to talk about why exactly
would be foolish for the President to
actually get in front of Muller with
some examples of President Trump being
President Trump because he continues to
be President Trump which has upsides and
it has downsides but first you're going
to have to go over to Daily wire calm
first let me announce let me remind you
it's here it's come the time has finally
come for me to take my podcast to live
audiences so tomorrow Dallas Texas
Wednesday August 15th in Phoenix Arizona
Thursday the 16th seats are just about
sold out you can still get a few
available tickets left
go over to Live Nation calm or
Ticketmaster calm search Ben Shapiro so
you don't miss it and we were gonna be
doing the live podcast when you're doing
a Q&A it's gonna be a blast thousands of
fellow ben shapiro show listeners are
gonna be there plus I will be there as
well because otherwise why would you be
there so go check that out over at Live
Nation calm or ticketmaster.com
also when you subscribe at daily wire
calm next time we have an event we have
a VIP section to get the first available
shot at that and you also get to listen
to the rest of the Andrew Clavin show
live he gets to listen and watch the
rest of the Michael Noel's show live I
thought he was fired unfortunately he
was not so he retains that show so go
check that out also if you get the
annual subscription for $99 a year it is
cheaper than the monthly and you get the
leftist tears hot or cold tumblr
everyone who tries this loves this thing
I mean I just I've not heard a single
complaint about this from anyone except
for a steven crowder legitimately so go
check that out right now
also subscribe over at YouTube or iTunes
we have a fantastic Sunday special
coming up next Sunday special is just
awesome you're gonna want to be a
subscriber to check that out we're the
largest fastest-growing conservative
podcast in the nation
[Music]
so the President of the United States if
everything feels chaotic it's because
everything just feels chaotic and it's
it's highly irritating it's gotta stop
none of it is very helpful the president
has news cycles from here to the end of
time that are that are quite good for
him
I think the economy is doing well we
don't have any major foreign crises
these this is one of the things I keep
emphasizing if the president would just
stay out of the news everything would be
better every time the president goes
abroad and the media doesn't have
anything to do but fulminate over over
nothing his approval ratings go up
instead the president has a nasty habit
of allowing his aide to dominate how he
approaches politics and that makes it
very hard for his fellow Congress the
Republican Congress people to get
elected I talked to Republicans who are
running in races across the country on a
routine basis and the biggest single
problem they have is that every election
is no longer a referendum on them it's a
referendum on President Trump and
president Trump is not popular in a lot
of swing districts so for all the talk
about Trump being litmus test for
Republicans I know a lot of Republicans
are enthusiastic about that because
Trump won in 2016 2016 you may notice on
the calendar is not the same date as
2018 nor is it the same date as 2020
what the president does actually matters
and so when the president is petty or
when the president gets into Twitter
space with Omarosa
or when the president is just musing
about struck and page and all the rest
of the stuff is any of this stuff
dramatically helpful no it's not an
example yesterday of just just how
unhelpful this is so president Trump he
was announcing a win for him okay it is
the John McCain National Defense
Authorization Act it is a massive
increase in defense spending that is a
good thing that is a win it's something
that he has touted for a very long time
all he has to do for the headline to be
good is just be a normal human like a
normal decent human John McCain as much
as president Trump doesn't like John
McCain is indeed an American Hero
hey John McCain underwent torture by the
Vietcong for years anytime and then when
he was offered his release he refused
his release on the grounds that he
didn't want to leave his guys behind for
that alone John McCain anism is an
American Hero forget all of the Senate
service forget what you think about his
politics that was heroic stuff and he
has always been a strong advocate for
the National Defense community so
there's his bill it's called the John s
McCain
National Defense Authorization here was
president Trump announcing the bill
you'll notice something missing in this
announcement in a few moments in honor
of that sacred obligation I will put my
signature on the National Defense
Authorization Act this authorization
will give America's war fighters the
firepower they need to win any conflict
quickly and decisively yeah all of
that's fine except for him completely
ignoring the name of the Act
he just completely ignores the name of
the Act and so people jumped on this as
well they should because it's kind of a
garbagey thing to do
hey John McCain was one of the forces
behind this act and then later he mocked
McCain in front of a crowd well
basically signing bill come on we got
rid of the individual mandate which is
the most everything but as you know one
of our one of our wonderful senators
said thumbs down at two o'clock in the
morning okay so there he is mocking
McCain the same day listen it's fine to
mount McCain for his political activity
but ignoring his name in the defense
authorization bill is kind of a it's
kind of a crappy move and this is the
biggest problem for president Trump
really he doesn't know his friends from
his enemies he doesn't know the people
who want him to succeed from the people
who don't want him to succeed okay the
fact is that he may not like John McCain
but when it comes to smacking John
McCain is that really an important thing
for him to be doing or should he be
saving his firepower for people who
actually deserve it so that was some bad
trim now here's some good Trump right
here's President Trump going after
Andrew Cuomo know Andrew Cuomo deserves
every bit of scorn the president can
utilize against him if president from
leverages his fire against Andrew Cuomo
that is a valid use of time so here is
the president doing the right thing by
attacking somebody who ought to be
attacked Cuomo wants to take away your
Second Amendment now he called me and he
said I'll never run for president
against you but maybe he wants to oh
please do it
[Applause]
he did say that did that maybe maybe he
mentioned the one thing we know and they
do say anybody that runs against Trump
suffers yeah this is the part of Trump
that's actually first of all it's very
funny but second of all this is the part
of Trump that's actually useful him
attacking Democrats is useful him
attacking people who are actively you
know trying to run against him that's a
useful thing what is not a useful thing
is all the distractions is all the
foolishness with with Omarosa yeah
there's been this take on President
Trump all along they get the good along
with the bad and that works until it
doesn't it works until it doesn't people
say well it helped him win in 2016 it
did help him win in 2016 but you know
what he lost the popular vote by three
million and he barely won the election
in the electoral college right he won
three states by 80,000 combined votes
and if you think that the same formula
is necessarily going to allow you to win
in 2020 even as you've doubled down on
all the qualities that may be unpopular
in the first place I am skeptical I'm
just skeptical now maybe Trump pulls it
out right Trump is very good at pulling
his opponents down into the mud this is
what he's best at and that's valid and
that's useful but if the president could
get even a little bit more disciplined
he'd have a much better shot of
maintaining Congress maintaining the
Senate maintaining the presidency if we
lose the Congress the Senate in the
presidency by 2020 people gonna look
back and say well maybe all of that the
good comes along with the bad stuff
maybe it would've been better if we just
gotten the good and not gotten a lot of
the bad I don't see why that's out of
the realm of possibility or why that is
being hypercritical with the president I
really don't think that it is now
speaking of
Cuomo's who stink Chris Cuomo on CNN
made a statement yesterday that is just
astonishing so as you've been following
we talked about it yesterday be fizzled
all right rally in Charlottesville 25
people showed up and then Antipa showed
up by the hundreds and proceeded to
attack some members of an Tifa proceeded
to attack the police they were walking
around chanting no no borders no wall no
USA at all really just wonderful
wonderful folks antiva going all the way
back to 2016 before Trump was president
the DHS the Department of Homeland
Security was suggesting that ante foe
was actually a threat to security across
the country at events across the country
yet the media have been propping them up
and for all the talk about how the right
needs
disassociate from the alt-right how the
right needs to basically disassociate
from folks like Cory Stewart in Virginia
and I think there's a lot of validity to
that I think Corey Stewart has been race
baiting for for no reason other than
political gain and it's gross in
Virginia for all the talk about how the
right needs to get rid of the Steve
bannon's and they need to get rid of the
the kind of alt right soft players in
the in the right wing movement the left
has embraced ante fits you far more of
an extent than the right currently
embraces they all right there's just no
question about this and the latest proof
of this is Chris Cuomo who legitimately
cannot bring himself to condemn antiva a
violent terrorist group in the United
States here is here's Chris Cuomo who is
I mean it's unbelievable to say this
because the less bright Cuomo I didn't I
didn't know that was possible it here's
Chris Cuomo actually saying on CNN that
there is no moral equivalency between
the Nazis and nt4 between the alt-right
and anti feh here's the argument if
you're a punk who comes to start trouble
in a mask and hurt people
you're not about any virtuous cause
you're just somebody who's gonna be held
to the standard of doing something wrong
but when someone comes to call out
bigots and it gets hot even physical are
they equally wrong as the bigot they are
fighting I argue no okay so he argues
that an Tifa is not as bad as the alt
writers ignoring the fact that 94 walks
around chatting about how all cops are
racist and how the system has to be torn
down about how the United States should
not exist okay it is exactly this
perspective on the part of the
mainstream left that will lead to
increased violence really it will lead
to the the belief that the mainstreaming
of violence is okay you label your
opponents Nazis and then you go out and
you protest them how do I know because
an see if I actually tried to do the
same thing at an actual speech that I
was giving okay I was the number one
target of the alt-right in 2016 there
was no mother has been no more vocal
voice against the alt-right in the
United States than me okay I've been
doing this for years ripping on them
consistently and yet an Tifa was there
at Berkeley trying to shut down my
speech okay but corn Chris Cuomo they're
just nice people right they're just
trying to fight the fascism the reality
is that antenna is an anarchist
communist at group there's sort of a
narco communists and they have been
pushing their radical politics for a
while using violence going all the way
back really to the sort of the World
Trade Organization protests in the 90s
there's a long lasting movement that
spans from the WTO through Occupy Wall
Street and now forward to an Tifa is all
part of
wave on the left and the fact that the
left still sees these people as fighting
on the beaches of Normandy is
astonishing remember Chris Cuomo is the
same idiot who when an Tifa actually got
violent tweeted out a picture of the
beaches at Normandy of our guys getting
off the beaches at Normandy and said
here's another group of anti-fascist
fighting a group of fascists and is like
wait a second so your suggestion is that
number one American citizens exercising
their right to free speech in the wrong
cause is the same as Nazis who
legitimately invaded several countries
and perpetrated the Holocaust got a
problem with that because why we have
law enforcement in the United States to
prevent bad stuff from happening second
of all if you really think that these
idiot anarchists who are throwing
bottles at cops are the same thing as
American soldiers getting off the boats
at Normandy to fight Nazis you're out of
your mind there were no white
supremacist who showed up two days ago
20 of them but there are hundreds of
Antipa members who are getting violent
shouting ridiculous things and yet the
media are defending them because the
media has embraced full-scale the
reactionary politics that makes this
country ugly they've embraced it and
this is what we are now seeing we are
seeing politics ping-ponging forth back
and forth between two reactionary points
of view you want to know how things
actually get violent you won't know how
a peaceful country or a country that has
a functioning democracy devolves into
violence and sectarianism the way it
happens is you feel that your group is
threatened by an out-group and so you
start pursuing ever more radical methods
of fighting that out group and in
response the out group feels threatened
by you and they start pursuing ever more
radical politics and violence as well
that's how things spiral out of control
and Chris Cuomo and folks like him who
are pushing an Tifa are only promoting
that they're only helping that case it's
really dangerous they're playing with
fire here they're playing if they had
any sense and actually look back at the
history of Nazi Germany and pre Nazi
Germany what they would have to
recognize is that one of the things that
led to the rise of the Nazis was the
fact that there were actual near daily
street fights between communists and
brown shirts on the streets of pre Nazi
Germany on the streets of the vemma
republic that led to the rise of the
Nazi government that really is a deep
part of the history of the media wish to
ignore simply because they want to claim
that everybody on the right is evil or
anyone tangentially associated with the
right is is a Nazi but everybody on the
left is actually good and Noble and
virtuous okay time for some things I
like and then we'll do
things that I hate so things that I like
Greg Gutfeld does a great job over on
the five and he has a brand new book
called the gutfeld monologues he has an
essay at the very beginning that's
really telling because gutfeld took the
same position I did in the 2016 election
he didn't vote for either of the
candidates and he talks about why that
was what has changed what his view is on
President Trump and then what he does he
takes a lot of his old monologues and he
does something that's really worthwhile
something I think that most commentators
actually should do he takes a lot of his
old writings then he critiques his own
his own writings now this is something
that I did recently on The Daily wire
when I was you know criticized for some
stuff I'd written in the past I felt
like okay well you know what why don't I
go back and actually see if that stuff
was bad or if it was good and it turns
out something it was bad and so it was
good you know I would say the vast
majority of what I've written over the
course of my career I'm proud of but
there's certain things that I've written
that are just garbage and Gutfeld does
the same thing in the Gutfeld monologues
it's worth reading it's a fun read I
think this number 5 on the Wall Street
Journal bestseller list this week so go
check it out
they got fill monologues with by by Greg
Gutfeld Greg's also a really good guy so
go check that out a really really nice
guy okay time for let's do some let's do
a bunch of stuff that I hate like a lot
of it so this is just amazing and also
amusing I don't know whether I like this
whether I hate this and it's sort of a
deconstruction of the culture so there's
a new show on CW about bat woman that
woman right not Batgirl bat woman
Batgirl is is Commissioner Gordon's
daughter that woman is the is a police
officer I guess like a former police
officer I remember her back story who
ends up fighting crime alongside Batman
in the new 52 comics which were released
what in the last decade or so in the new
52 series they made her lesbian because
when they launched new 52 they decided
they were gonna go broad scale diverse
so everybody was going to be a Muslim or
black or gay because they wanted a
broader spectrum of characters who are
not all white straight people that's
their creative decision I would suggest
that that creativity was drawn was was
pushed less by character and necessity
than it was by a desire to be
politically correct if you read a lot of
the new 52 comics have been critical of
them for years because they've attempted
to leverage left politics into comic
books in matters ranging from
immigration to sexuality they've had
full comic books were Superman is is
fighting the is basically a member of an
Tifa
the police so remember black lives
matter the new 52 has become very very
much to the left in any case the
character of that woman has been a
lesbian in the new 52 for probably a
decade close to a decade and now they're
making a series on CW about bat woman
and so she is a lesbian of course now
we'll see how that plays on network
television whether people are all that
interested in watching a character who
is a lesbian full time maybe yes maybe
no who knows whatever not a huge deal
however it was a huge deal to the left
why was it a huge deal to the left
because they insisted on the left that
you needed a lesbian to play a lesbian
in the same way they need a transgender
person to play a transgender person and
a cat woman to play Catwoman like a
woman who's a cat you need to play a
natural cat woman you also need a
lesbian to play a lesbian so CW trying
to hone in on that decided you know what
why don't we cast a ruby rose so Ruby
Rose you'll remember maybe from the
latest John wick movie I haven't seen
her in a lot of stuff but she's a decent
actress she can she plays solid really
well i and she is bisexual so she is not
a full-scale lesbian she calls herself
gender fluid so she is male something
she feels male some days and she feels
female others and she's bisexual and
she's pansexual and all this kind of
stuff okay but here's the problem nobody
on the right cares about this stuff
right nobody on the right is like oh
that's just terrible how did everyone on
the Left win not she had to quit Twitter
why did she quit Twitter because
hilariously enough the left decided she
was not lesbian enough she was bisexual
not a full-scale lesbian and that meant
she was just not enough of a lesbian for
her to play the the sainted character of
bat woman according to the Washington
Post some corners of Twitter and
Instagram are criticizing actors who
have been cast to play gay characters on
screen leading one of them to abandon a
platform over the weekend an Australian
actress Ruby Rose quit Twitter and shut
down public commenting on her Instagram
account after receiving backlash over
her being cast as bat woman for Greg
Berlanti series of arrowverse shows on
CW by the way I believe Craig Berlanti
is gay as well so it's not like the guy
doesn't have an interest in LGBT issues
part of the fear is centered on
representation of DC Comics superhero
who is a lesbian and the actress sweetie
where on earth did Ruby is not a lesbian
therefore she can't be bat woman come
from has to be the funniest most
ridiculous thing I've ever read I came
out at 12 and have for the past five
years had to deal with these she's too
gay how do you all flip it like
says I didn't change I wish we would all
support each other and our journeys she
says that she has identified as
gender-fluid and she's I guess also on
orange is the new black and you know
Janelle Monae came out in her favor I
guess Janelle Monae is also a lesbian or
bisexual and I can't remember her
sexuality because I frankly don't care
at all but what I love is the fact that
she is gender fluid so she's not gay
enough also the character is Jewish but
Roby Ruby roses in Jewish so I guess
that she can't play a Jewish person I
guess Sheldon Cooper can no longer play
a straight person because the character
the guy who plays Sheldon Cooper on Big
Bang Theory is actually a gay guy right
so he can't play a straight person I
guess that Eric Stonestreet who plays
cam on Modern Family and is actually a
straight guy he can no longer play a gay
guy nobody can play anything they're not
actors have to be the actual parts every
TV show has to be a reality show
Superman actually has to be able to fly
so it's gonna make casting really really
difficult there are a lot of people who
wanted to see Ashley Platts get the role
I guess because she's a lesbian so I
guess she's more lesbian so now we're
having lesbian competitions I will say
that I may put this in things that I
like because I really am enjoying a I
really am enjoying a lot the left eating
its own it's pretty it's pretty
spectacular watching the left think that
it is not leftist enough so that that's
pretty great okay another thing that I
hate so Politico has an article from
Stephen Miller's uncle because this is
the thing that we're gonna do now we're
gonna go find every relative who doesn't
like you and have them write op-eds so
Stephen Miller is of course the very
anti-immigration both illegal and legal
immigration guy in the Trump
administration he was the top
legislative aide to Jeff Sessions who
sort of his top strategist and I
remember being at a dinner with Ann
Coulter and Stephen Miller and Jeff
Sessions in which they discussed
immigration for like three hours well
everyone else is bored out of their
skull so this has been Steven Miller's
bag for a very long time well now his
uncle is getting in on the act he writes
a piece for Politico in which he talks
about how Stephen Miller is just wrong
about that he says let me tell you a
story about Stephen Miller and chain
migration it begins at the turn of the
20th century in a dirt floor Shack in
the village of Antep all a shtetl of
subsistence farmers and what is now
Belarus beset by violent anti-jewish
pogroms forced childhood conscription in
the Czar's army the patriarch of the
shack wolf liebe Gloucester
fled a village where his forebears had
lived for centuries and took his chances
in America he set foot on Ellis Island
on January 7th 1903 with 8 bucks to his
name
the fluent in Polish Russian and Yiddish
he understood no English in elder son
Nathan soon followed by street corner
peddling and sweatshop toil Wolfe liebe
and Nathan sent enough money home to pay
off debts and by the immediate family's
passage to America in 1906 and these
would of course be the eventual
great-grandparents of Stephenville
great-great grandparents of Stephen
Miller
so is he glossaries his maternal
grandfather Stephens mother Miriam is my
sister
I have watched with dismay and
increasing horror is my nephew an
educated man who is well aware of his
heritage has become the architect of
immigration policies that repudiate the
very foundation of our families life in
this country okay so here's the part
about this I don't like you wanna make
an immigration argument fine you want to
suggest that our immigration policies
are too restrictive on legal immigration
I'm actually interested in hearing that
argument cuz I think that they're a good
arguments to be made on both sides of
that particular issue if you want to
make the case that relatives of
politically popular figures are now
authorities on what those politically
popular figures should be saying I got a
problem with that like are we gonna our
family off-limits or his family not
off-limits I mean this is a serious
question because what we heard for years
that Chelsea Clinton was off-limits
until she wasn't off-limits and now
she's off-limits again I guess because
Hillary is no longer politically active
when our relatives off-limits like when
they decide to be off-limits or when
they don't decide to be off-limits and
beyond that I don't know why we care
what Steven Miller's uncle has to say
about things and why would that possibly
matter I have lots of relatives I
disagree with the vast majority of them
on politics I'm a Jew that means most of
my relatives are on the Left does that
mean that my uncles and aunts have some
sort of deeply valuable perspective on
my heritage that I do not you know
because I have parents who are part of
that heritage as well I find all this
incredibly stupid but the left has no
rules when it comes to attacking folks
on the right and so we're gonna dig up
random relatives to go after people all
of that is incredibly dumb okay we'll be
back here at tomorrow and we will be
broadcasting from Dallas so go check out
our event if you are in Dallas I believe
there are a few tickets left over to
Live Nation or Ticketmaster and get a
few of the remaining tickets if you're
in Phoenix then the following day we are
going to be broadcasting from there as
well so go check that out I'm Ben
Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Sonia Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer is Mathis
Glover and our technical producer is
Austin Stevens edited by Alex and Garo
audio is mixed by Mike Carmina hair and
makeup is by Jess wah al Vera the Ben
Shapiro show is a daily wire for word
publishing production copyright Ford
publishing 2018